what's going on everybody it's Michael B
Jordan and I'm going undercover on the
Internet
I plan on answering some of your
comments that you never thought I would
respond to some questions and just clear
up some things on internet that you guys
possibly didn't know this is actually me
so first up we got Twitter I had Michael
B Jordan why didn't you rap on the Black
Panther album you too talented not to
have a bar to a man I appreciate the
faith music has never been one of my
strong points during all-star weekend
down in New Orleans and he was like two
years ago I opened up with the roots
kind of a spoken word rap kind of thing
and that was it for me jay-z said I did
a good job so I need to here retire from
the music industry next if Michael B
Jordan has actually trained like a real
boxer for creed and Creed - why doesn't
he go into professional boxing he's been
eating four to five meals a day been
working out three times a day he knows
how it goes he has a routine why not
compete professionally i'ma leave that
to the professionals
I'm an actor acting like a boxer that
step next you to real life can you fight
though
question mark yeah I got these hands see
me next next up we got it ready marbles
Black Panther all this for me I tweeted
this great marvel's Black Panther would
love to go toe to toe with Iron Man and
the Hulk definitely would be a dream
roll video audition for a black panther
and got kill monger I think that's what
I think that's good that's what with Tom
little singing with Thor okay I'm gonna
work on grammar than that no I never
audition for black damn take me around
it really close as soon as he got the
directing job you know he hit me up and
we talked about you know possibly
playing a villain he thought it would be
a good good move for me I never kind of
played a character that was uh you know
that intense you know the antagonist you
build the character and rest is history
next Michael B Jordan buys a teen a new
retainer app that she bit through it
during his shirtless black panther
sweet gesture I'm just confused about
logistics of this like how did it break
I don't really know how exactly she
broke it I'm guessing she bit through it
maybe but yeah I sent her a DM and I
asked her if I could pay for a retainer
she she declined I asked a couple times
she declined but uh whenever I'm in the
Bay Area
I plan on meeting up with her and giving
her a picture that was a trade-off
so next pic opinion in March 2017 it was
reported that Warner Brothers wants to
cast Jordan as a younger version of
Morpheus in a possible prequel of the
matrix yeah I think it was a rumor I
read that too somewhere next back to
Twitter what do you think might be
Jordan's favorite anime is it's a good
question favorite anime is in the road
to Shippuden being a fan of it for years
cuz I was like maybe 12 13 years old
I've literally seen Sasuke and Rose who
grow up at the end of it it was pretty
sad I drop a couple tears enter my Betty
[ __ ] with samurai champloo yes yes I do
and FLCL doesn't mean I'm not a tree
anime fan I just don't know what that is
next up IMDB took tap-dancing lessons as
a child my mom is forever embarrassing
me yes I took tap-dancing lessons when I
was a kid was the first place like I
actually catch the bus to by myself and
that was the trade-off and I went a
couple years pretty decent shut up the
Gregory Hines and Savion Glover awesome
he was offered the role of dr. Dre and
Straight Outta Compton I was you know
amazing story obviously Dre's and
credibly talented Legend I just didn't
think you know how we write for it
can they cast it the perfect guy you
know I don't think anybody else could
have done it
you know kudos they did an amazing run
movies awesome next next up Instagram
when will we see a buddy cop comedy from
the both of y'all hey you know he's busy
I'm busy but yeah I think you might see
something from us in that future you
never know we might be cooking up
something right now so that's it I'm
signing off the internet but I hope I
answered it you know most of your
questions and comments and cleared up
some things yeah that's it see I think
that's what with Tom Hiddleston with
Thor